monsieur pateras bonsoir bonsoir alors
en parcourant votre livre ça m'a rappelé
tous et tous ces noms qu'on a connu dans
la mode québécoise au fil des décennies
de ses boutiques de créateurs qu'on a
fréquenté de ses marques qu'on a connu
et qu'on apportait et qu'on a un peu
oublié parce que c'est pour ça que vous
avez fait ce livre
ah oui en fait ses devoirs de mémoire il
m'interpellait depuis depuis 15 ans
parce qu'il ya eu une série de deux
personnes importantes de la main du
milieu de la mode qui nous ont quittés à
moins de deux ans d'intervalle de la
grande journaliste à oyonnax monal et
aux chevaliers cave est un peu mon
parrain dans la mode à john walton a
créé d'autres gens ils sont partis dans
l'indifférence la plus totale
moi ça va creuser le cas je voulais être
démontré que le québec avec tout ça
l'est toujours comme de vie je me
souviens parce que vous savez c'est les
français et les italiens sont si fiers
de leur mode sait qui ils la connaissent
et dont l'un très belle histoire on ne
met elle est méconnue et moi je me suis
dit pendant que je suis là j'ai posé un
regard sur sur tous ces gens que j'aime
et que je fréquente mais le monde des
mannequins des photographes aussi des
créateurs des créatrices parce qu'il lui
disait paul aussi laquelle dérive où
était la plus foisonnante en termes
d'idées justement et de reconnaissance
du talent de la mode québécoise
je crois qu'il ya eu deux grandes
époques là en fait 3 parce que dès les
années 50 rendez compte
les premiers coups de curieux se
mobiliser c'est la robe cocktail dior la
grande époque la haute couture française
est là tout est basé sur finalement
l'exemple france parisien les salons de
coude sur marie paule noëlle et jacques
de montjoye et tous ceux qui ont formé
la première association née tout de
suite on va montrer notre mode
savoir-faire à new york à l'hôtel pierre
de ta main
bien sûr notre prêt-à-porter ça ça
semble clichés de parler de l'expo 67
mais ça a été la l'épreuve le premier
mouvement de démocratisation de la mode
avec
toute cette nouvelle vague de commencer
déjà dans les années 50 la note le
prêt-à-porter naissait déjà dans ces
années là le prêt-à-porter est vraiment
né dans les années 60 mais vraiment
c'était plus l'esprit de la haute
couture qui flottait sur les années 50
et puis là il ya eu la révolution alors
donc tout à coup michel robichaud
marielle fleury crg real on fait tous
les costumes des hôtesses de l'expo 67
et là tout à coup les premières l'aller
les manufacturiers qui était très très
traditionnels se sont dit mais il faut
années de l'originalité tout ça et là
ils ont engagé finalement il ya eu des
partenariats extraordinaire à ce moment
là et moi pour moi le foisonnement des
années 80 on a connu le pire et le
meilleur
vous vous votre griffe est sorti dans
les années sans dessein notre première
boutique à ces années 60
non mais c'est drôle parce que je
n'aimais pas beaucoup la mode des années
70 et c'est pour ça que oui c'est ça je
me suis dit moi je m'identifie pas cette
mode là parce que moi j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup la mode masculine avec ses
belles mathias et pureté des lignes de
fort nous tous et je suis arrivé avec
une collection très très masculine pour
les femmes c'est à dire des grands
trench-coat des grands la mode j'étais
tellement je me suis tellement identifié
à ça et puis tout à coup les années 80
ça a été tellement des années
extravagantes on passe à des diagnostics
même les gens de manivelle ça que j'ai
habillé à la fin de l'heure oui oui
c'est complètement délirant quand je
montrais mes collections à new york et
tout mais moi je retiens des années 80
surtout la beauté avec les japonais qui
ont complètement révolutionné la mode et
mia collet yamamoto et sacrifient si la
mode québécoise mais un certain niveau
aurait été quelques uns à être très
inspiré par les japonais notamment
georges lévesque j'ai tellement aimé moi
c'est sûr que j'avais toujours aidé du
japon je vivais en kimono toujours à la
maison mais quand j'ai pu m'acheter mon
premier kimono
à l'âge de 15 ans vont lui faire et
cette pureté des lignes des formes chez
les japonais ce côté finalement aussi
enveloppe en caressant les vêtements des
japonais ça j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup aimé ça et puis on a eu des
creux et des bosses mais non il faut le
dire oui mais vous dirais donc que les
années les années 80 72 80 étaient les
meilleures années de la mode québécoise
en termes de créativité et de et
d'expansion
oui jusqu'à au milieu des années 90 en
fait on était totalement la tendance
dans la reconnaissance d'un autre mode
elle était portée elle était supporter
aussi par des détaillants les grands
magasins avaient tous leur section
québécoise
absolument et surtout quand la boutique
revanche est arrivé sur la vie saint
denis là c'était tout à coup de la
valorisation de nos couturiers puis tout
à coup les années les années 90 sont
arrivés sas a bien démarré mais là il ya
eu des faillites retentissantes et c'est
ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce que c'est
pas ça a été vraiment tout à coup
l'envahissement de la globalisation qui
a commencé alors les grands magasins
européens à bas prix sont arrivés les
winners ce monde sont entrés en jeu et
tout à coup c'était la course au plus
bas prix alors donc ça a été la
production qui s'est transférée en
orient ça a été plusieurs manufactures
ici ont fermé leurs portes à ce moment
là et là ça a été le début de la fin je
vire donc on en a vraiment on a beaucoup
beaucoup souffert on s'est relevés
depuis parce que chance je suis très
positif mois pour ce qui se passe en ce
moment je vois ce que j'allais vous le
demander c'est sûr que des villes comme
paris londres ou new york sont
considérés comme des capitales de la
mode et que c'est une véritable
industrie qui se suffit à elle-même
j'imagine alors qu'à montréal on peut
pas en dire autant c'est pas une
capitale de la mode mais a énormément
créativité ici
est ce que est ce que cette industrie et
ses créateurs sont suffisamment soutenu
voilà réduit tout est là je crois que la
créativité dc est extraordinaire je
pense qu'on vit une époque formidable
parce que montréal
cesser de se comparer à paris à londres
à 1000 un peu importe montréal et
montréal
on le voit dans la culture montréalaise
au niveau du cinéma de la musique et
tout est vraiment montréal et après se
positionner comme étant une ville en
marge et ça c'est formidable
d'autant plus que dans les écoles c'est
extraordinaire ce qui se passe mais je
parle de toutes les écoles de mode et
aussi de cuir d'impression textile et
tous qui s'unissent et avec la force de
ces écoles là qui finalement ont l'appui
maintenant des musées aussi parce que
les musées tout à coup le mais collent à
montréal le musée de la civilisation à
québec s'impose comme des vitrines
incontournables de la mode d'ici aussi
alors donc il ya cette espèce de
dynamique où les jeunes ont appris dans
ces écoles à à dessiner à collaborer la
notion du co2 sein de la co création et
ça change la halle pour démarrer son
atelier boutique pour commencer dans
milieu sort c'est bien d'avoir du talent
c'est bien d'avoir des écoles mais après
il faut continuer et là c'est la quitte
en corse à notre faiblesse c'est que les
gens d'affaires ne sont pas là pour
soutenir nos créateurs et non créatrice
comment en france ou ailleurs dans le
monde
ce sont des groupes financiers non mon
pinceau lvmh de ce monde et tout mais là
cette espèce de concertation avec la
gratte m mode avec le festival mode et
design aussi qu'entre en jeu
on dirait qu'il ya toute une ville tout
le québec s'est mobilisée pour changer
la donne et là il faut convaincre les
gens d'affaires de l'avenir tout à fait
d'investir un regard en terminant
monsieur poitras sur la mode aujourd'hui
on a vu on a parcouru rapidement des
années 50 à aujourd'hui et la mode s'est
toujours adaptée à son époque 1 est-elle
reflets un peu quand françois années 60
70 c'était le reflet d'émancipation la
liberté vestimentaire de liberté tout
court
on a vu la nuit je puis tout ça les
choses mais aujourd'hui la mode reflète
croix comme phénomène social ben moi je
crois que c'est incroyable chacun
cherche sa tribu lui un ou deux quand on
voit par exemple à quel point la mode ne
cesse de se redéfinir de cette influence
de retourner à ses origines tout à coup
on va voir les années 60 qui reviennent
les années 80 et tout mais à la sauce
aujourd'hui et tous les jeunes je crois
entre dans ce mouvement de chacun
cherche sa tribu mai dernier vous en
même temps que les gens s'habillent la
moindre recherche dans l'habillement
aujourd'hui dans les rues des grandes
villes je pense à mon pays à montréal à
d'autres oui mais moi j'ai eu très très
peur de la globalisation et de la
surconsommation et celles de certains
magasins on change finalement les
collections les vêtements aux trois
semaines c'est pas possible
moi je viens d'une école et c'est pour
ça que j'ai délaissé le prêt-à-porter un
moment donné parce que j'avais
l'impression que moi je n'ai d'une école
où je croyais à la beauté d'une matière
là bas parce que j'avais une grand-maman
notamment qui avait sa robe du dimanche
qui avait sans date du dimanche et qui
était pourtant d'une famille extrêmement
modeste mais je me souviens qu'un jour
elle avait mis sa nappe sanaa du
dimanche et elle avec voulu garder mes
tantes à la maison pour dîner pour
souper et tout à coup une de mes tantes
avait dit mais comment vous êtes procuré
cette fabuleuse n'a tout fait à la main
et tout est perdu sa voix sa grand maman
elle avait dit jda lançant l avait dit
mais on est trop pauvre pour ne pas
acheter de la qualité alors moi à
l'heure de lui prête à jeter j'étais
plus capable parce que je viens de cette
école du bo intemporel de la ligne
temporelle la beauté des matières et
tout et je fais mais là aujourd'hui a
tout à coup le mouvement slow qu'on voit
évidemment dans dans la cuisine et tout
mais le slow fashion vieille en
opposition justement à cette
surconsommation et l'asse partout dans
le mile end dans les petits ateliers et
tous qu'on veut savoir qui est derrière
qui a fait cette robe ce vêtement est il
là je crois qu'il ya un seul ce retour
du balancier exceptionnel jean claude
poitras c'est un livre à lire si on veut
se rappeler toutes ces bonnes années et
on espère qu'il y en a encore plusieurs
autres décennies de mode québécoise
merci beaucoup merci à vous pour voir